bonjour jean d'hier à et merci être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
le voit les partis indépendantistes qui
sont en tête des résultats partiels de
sept élections régionales quelle est la
réaction en catalogne est ce que c'est
un succès historique
écoutez c'est la première fois que les
forces indépendantistes dépasse les 50%
intel 50 est en hausse de 10 %
exactement et jusqu'à présent badri t
disait toujours oui les 14 remporté les
élections mais ya pas une majorité
favorable à l'indépendance
aujourd'hui on peut dire que les
indépendantistes non seulement obtenu la
majorité des sièges au parlement
il obtient aussi la majorité des
électeurs et donc c'est un changement
c'est important des citations
jusqu'aujourd'hui madrid devra donner de
réponse alors une première également
dans ces élections c'est la victoire du
parti d'extrême droite vox qui sort
vainqueur en sont si on peut le dire de
cette élection
on sait que le parti d'extrême droite a
joué sur une campagne de communication
assez agressive c'est c'est le résultat
finalement aujourd'hui géré et éthiques
l'extrême-droite et elle existe et elle
était intégrée partie de la droite déjà
aujourd'hui comme partout cet espace
politique existe une réalité et il fait
partie des gros clients nist donc aucun
changement parce que toutes les voix qui
change est encore plus de 50% donc des
voix pour les indépendantistes après
voilà cette tentative de sécession il y
a trois ans qu'est-ce que cela symbolise
pour la catalogne
mais aujourd'hui la question catalan les
touches matin et il ya des questions qui
sont fondamentales à la première et si
l'ami 6 pour tous les prisonniers
politiques et plus de 30000 personnes
qui sont poursuivies et d'autre part la
réalisation d'un référendum
reconnu par l'espagne pour compte
international c'est l'ordre du jour donc
j'en ai à venir et pour enseigner en
fait on peut dire c'est que on est
partis de loin pour revenir au même
endroit le refus du pouvoir central
espagnol d'accepter les décisions des
caravanes je vous lis il revient parmi
les quatre amis d'une façon persévérant
à soutenir indépendantiste est ce que
pour la première fois
voilà ce résultat laisse entrevoir une
possibilité de dialogue avec madrid
l'écouté aujourd'hui le dialogue
c'était un dialogue de sourds ça va pas
demander surtout les catalans je me suis
battu formation un terrain il faudrait
que pour 8 fasse des propositions envers
les catalans ça n'a jamais été le cas on
attend et on verra bien s'il ya un
espace de discussion possible
mais jusqu'à présent c'était non à tout
et non à tous ces avancées il faut
maintenant que madrid qui en résulte est
la 4ème fois dans le panneau il ya une
majorité absolue au parlement qui est un
nom pour vous pas et que ça ne
disparaîtra pas
delta qui l'état de discuter et négocier
et d'arriver à la organiser un scrutin
en pleine pandémie c'était un pari
démocratique aux et on a vu le taux
d'abstention à un taux d'abstention
record 46 % d'abstention est ce que vous
regrettez justement que voilà que ces
élections ont finalement eu lieu on
aurait peut-être pu attendre un petit
peu que l la pandémie fasse moins de
victimes
j'avais raison mais c'était par des
juges espagnols
la date de l'élection a été obligatoire
la voile en catalan les routes et dans
d'autres camps mois mais ces deux sur le
juge espagnol qui a obligé donc
la cour supérieure la catalogne qui est
l émanation de la cour suprême espagnol
a obligé à réaliser le bois justement
aux quatorze 14 février et ce n'était
pas la meilleure des occasions mais
finalement peu importe aujourd'hui c'est
en beauté démocratique
il a été réalisé avec les règles de jeu
qui ont été dictées par le pouvoir
central
et même avec des difficultés qu'ils
étaient nombreuses les indépendantistes
au milieu des élections merci beaucoup
jordi vera d'avoir réagi ce matin je
rappelle que vous êtes coordinateur du
mouvement oui au pays catalan